where is uh colin
in the back
uh
you you wrote a question about a wedding
love a trashy wedding
well
uh have you ever been to a potluck
wedding
a potluck wedding
what what did you take i have to know
what did you make man
you pulled you took a spiral man to a
wedding
let me ask you this
let me ask you this was it honey baked
absolutely
did
how many people yeah how many hams did
you take
i need hamster 135 people he got it he
got a half a pound sliced in at the
delta
it's every minute for themselves
everybody mustered yeah
don't use the foreheads give me give me
the cheap [ __ ] though wait i gotta how
many people are at this wedding 120 120.
you brought one [ __ ] ham
i'd have been cursing you out in the
parking lot
what the [ __ ]
open bar though yeah
did you also give a gift as well
what'd you give how much cash
they gave her
200 bucks in a turkey
but uh whose wedding was it was a good
friend of mine
buddy re-evaluate some [ __ ]
if a good friend of mine invited me to a
potluck wedding they would no longer be
a good friend of mine
i honestly hope he does
oh he listens i don't know oh is he here
i mean
this isn't on like sirius xm or anything
be great if he just reign in the
bathroom yeah
you said you liked it you said it was a
good idea
he said the buffalo chicken dip was good
my mom made those deviled eggs
god damn kyle
what
i just think about all those casserole
dishes having to go back
you know
imagine going to won't have to do dishes
the next morning
oh [ __ ] up i gotta grab my crockpot
i'll be back in here
i don't wanna crack pop out of dj booth
just call the guy call the guy i'll meet
you in a minute
just tell him to hurry up
i ate too much ham
trying to get coke after a wedding with
a casserole dish
man what the [ __ ] do you get into
tonight
[Laughter]
jesus god dude
uh it says not really a question but i
feel it's spitting i have a black guy
and i start a new job on monday
boston
you're [ __ ] trash we love the [ __ ]
out of here
holy [ __ ]